so you emceed your own wedding yeah  yeah I just couldn't stay away I saw a  microphone and I'm like I need that DJs  will always play you know like songs  that maybe get the ladies turned up and  I decided to play back that ass I'm just  thinking  it's a wedding right we're all gonna  know this is tongue-in-cheek  didn't I don't know what no it went over  fine I don't know what it is about that  song I put it on and just an instinct  tapped in and then everyone just  everyone's just starting to bend a lot  lower  you know everyone's starting to shake  his aunt was working it dude people  started shaking some ass  I don't like family I mean Mima was  throwing ass  I don't know who my second aunt was but  Brad am I blood related to her she's  throwing that [ __ ] bro  that's my aunt though  she slides the ring off